地球で遊ぶっていうことが大好きですで
地球でこう全身を使って
自分の能力を最大限に使ってこう遊ぶって
いうことをまあ
第一にして遊んできてそれが
ライフスタイルでありそれが今の職業に
伝わるつながってますでそういったことを
そこの経験をしてきた中でいろいろ感じた
こととかありますのでぜひ今日は皆さんに
お伝えできればと思います
世界中の山々にスキーを通じて挑戦する
ことになったんですけどもやっぱりそこに
至るまでにはたくさんのきっかけがあり
ましたその中で3つすごい大きなきっかけ
がありましたのでまずはその1つ目の
きっかけですね小学校の頃に植村なおみ
さんという人の
著書に出会ったのが1つ目のきっかけで
植村直己さんは
大陸の最高峰世界で初めて登場した方です
けども山登りだけじゃなくて
Amazonが
筏を手作りで作った
イカダで下ったりとかあとは犬ぞりを使っ
てグリーンランドを縦断したり
北極点に到達たりとかもう本当に
地球上様々な場所で冒険を繰り広げてきた
方ですねでその方の著書に出会って小学校
の頃
僕もいつかこういった色々な世界の面白い
ところでこう
ワクワクするようなことをしたいなと思っ
てましたただあの小学生の少年がいきなり
やっぱり山の世界に入ることっていうのは
難しかったですあの裏山とかそういった
ところで遊んでたんですけどもやっぱり
どんどんどんどん世界を広げたくなった
その時に2つ目の出会いがありまして
山岳ガイドの宮下孝夫さんという人に
出会ったんですねで中学高校とこのガイド
のもとで僕は山登り
沢登り岩登りアイスクライニング山スキー
すごいたくさんのこうジャンのことを一緒
に経験させてもらって
知識や技術を身につけましたで高校卒業後
僕はそのまま
山岳ガイドという道を選びました
で高校卒業して2年間は
山のガイドの見習いをして
冬の間はスキーの集合修行してこいという
ことで
テネハイランドにある
三浦雄一郎さんのスキースクールの
インストラクターとして資料になさいまし
た
三浦さんの横でこうピッと顔出しているの
が19歳の僕なんですけどもあのここの
スキースクールであの三浦雄一郎さん皆
さんご存知でしょうか
えっとですね日本人で植村直己さんが
初めてエベレストに登庁したその時に
三浦栄一郎さんはエベレストの山頂の
ちょっと下から
直格好で
斜面の下まで滑り降りるという大冒険をし
た人なんですけどもそういったスキー
スクールの中で
月の先生をしながら僕は毎日朝から晩まで
スキーの修行をしました
昼間はスキーのレッスンとかをやってるん
ですけどもあのスキーを練習したくて夜は
夕食を食べた後もナイタースキーが終わる
までスキーを滑り続けて
帰りは家に帰る途中もう疲れすぎて車で
こう雪の壁をこう擦りながら
買えるような毎日を送っていったっていう
のを覚えてます
でやっぱりそこでこう山の知識スキーの
知識そういったことをまあすごいバランス
よくやっていたので
山岳スキーという世界で
活躍することになってきます20歳になっ
たらエクストリームスキーというちょっと
こう
過激なスキーの世界大会というものがあり
ましてそれに出て
世界大会に出て最高で
世界で第2位という生活
成績を収めて20代の頃はそういった大会
に出て
自分の中でアスリートとして世界のトップ
を目指すということで
スキーを続けましたこれから見ていただく
ビデオはそういった
スキーの
究極のスキーみたいな映像をちょっと
まとめたんですけどもあのスキーってです
ねゲレンデで滑るスキーとはちょっと
やっぱり
変わってくるんですけども
自然が作り上げた地形の中で人間が
すごい一番ダイナミックにこう
なんですその環境を楽しめるスポーツだ
なーって僕は思っていて僕が一番こう
やっぱりそこにフォーカスしてるんですね
で時にはこうシャドウ50°cぐらいの急
斜面を滑ることもできますし時には時速
100キロを超えるようなスピードも出
たりあとはこうジャンプをすれば
スキージャンプだったら100mぐらい
飛びますよね
僕もまあ40メートルぐらいまでは飛んだ
ことあるんですけど
本当にこう大きな大きな地球が作り上げた
地形でそこに
降り積もった雪を本当にこう体を使って
最大限に楽しめるっていうのがこういう
山岳スキーかなと思ってそのスキーを続け
てきました
それでですねあのこういったこう
究極のスキーを追い求めるのと同時に
やっぱりこう自然の中で遊ぶっていうこと
が好きだったのであの
仲間たちと海外の山に挑戦するそういう
ような機会もありましたで一番最初に
出かけた山が
北米大陸最高峰の
末金利ですね
マッキンリーというのは
6000Mを超える山でマイナス20度と
か寒いような読まないなんですよねで
やっぱりあのすごい厳しいんですけども僕
たちはいい仲間に恵まれてとにかくこう
その瞬間を楽しもう山にストイックに
向かうだけじゃなくて楽しもうということ
でどうですかね楽しさは溢れてます
でしょうか
こういう感じでこんな仲間なんですけども
21日間
山に挑戦して山頂に上がって
山頂から滑ることができましたでこの経験
を得たことで我々は
北海道でこうずっと楽しんで山をやってき
た僕たちだけども力を合わせればいろんな
山に挑戦できるということが気がついて
翌2001年には北島列島のパラムシル島
という島に来ました
カムチャッカがあって北海道があって間に
ある千島列島の一番北の端にあるパラムシ
とでここでまあ我々はスキーをしたわけな
んですけど実はこの場所
くじら浜っていう名前がついていて
昔太平洋戦争の時代にはここは日本の領土
でここには缶詰工場がありました
でそこで僕がこうあの
学んだというか
覚えたというか出会ったことで一番覚えて
いることは実はここのパラメシルトの
向かいにあるシムシ島っていうのは
終戦直後に
ソ連軍が攻め込んできたんですねでソ連軍
はその当時北海道を
占領しようとして攻め込んできたわけなん
ですねで終戦したんですけども日本軍が
そこですごい頑張ってあの足を留めてくれ
たそういう歴史があって今我々が住んで
いるこの北海道っていうのが日本のまま
だっていうそういう歴史にこの
遊びを通じて知ることができたっていう
ことで
すごいこう平和の中で僕たちは
遊ばしてもらっているなっていうのを
改めて感じます
で2003年ですね今度はグリーンランド
世界で2番目にこう氷河の表彰の大きい島
なんですけどもそこに
スキーで冒険出かけましたちょっと見え
づらいんですけども
左下にカヤックがシーカヤックが3
隻浮かんでます
フィールド
氷河で削られた
入江がこうずっと奥まで続いてるんです
けど道なんてないんですねなので
シーカヤックにキャンプ道具を積んで1
週間2週間かけて旅をして
スキーをするっていう旅をしましたでこの
シーカヤックっていうのは
地元のイヌイットの人たちが
カヤックを使って狩りをするために作った
ものなんですけども
我々は
獲物を取るんじゃなくて
良いパウダースノートよい
斜面を目指すためにそのシー火薬を使って
旅をして山を滑るというような旅をしまし
た
で右側にちょっとこうおにぎり状の山が
あってその中には舗装多い子を岩の隙間に
斜面があるんですねであの斜面を見た時に
我々はあそこ今日の夕日が当たる綺麗な
斜面じゃないかっていうことであの斜面を
滑りたいってことでこの後この島に
たどり着いて
夕日10時ぐらいに夕日になるんですけど
も
山を登ってこういったところ滑る
やっぱりあのこういう
冒険旅行っていうのは行ったこともない
地図もないような場所なんで初めてそこで
出会うでその出会った山の中で自分たちの
遊び場として最高の場所を選んでそこに
登ってチャレンジして滑るっていうすごい
満足度があるような
旅です
2007年ですね今度は南米のパタゴニア
に行きました
南米のパタゴニアも
フィヨルドが発達しているのでシー
カヤックを使って旅をしたんですけども
その時ですねあの地元のプンタレナンスと
いう街で
面白い
ゾーンに出会いました
でこれはですねあの
地元のもう絶滅してしまった先住民のヤー
ガン族っていう人たちの像なんですけど
ここに行くとですね地元の人や仲間にを
大輔がいるって言われるんですねちょっと
どうですかこんな感じなんですけどあの
言われるんですよであのここだけじゃなく
てカムチャッカ
半島でもグリーンランドでも僕地元に行く
と地元の人間にあれってお前なんか日本人
じゃなくてここら辺の人じゃないって言わ
れるんですねやっぱ調べたところを1万年
ぐらい前ですねあの昔氷河期に陸続きだっ
た土地を使ってやっぱりアジアの人たちが
こんな南米パタゴニアの方まで行っている
それを知った時にちょっと思ったんですね
なんで僕たちはこういう見たことない
ところに興味を覚えるんだろうと
もしかしたら昔の人はもしかしたらあの
食べ物を得るっていうことが一番の目的で
はあったと思うんですけどもやっぱりこう
新しい世界を見てみたい
多分そういうようなものもあってこう
ずっと長い長い旅をしてこの南米の先端
まで行ったんじゃないかななので人間我々
人間にはこういったこう
野生の
旅をしたい新しいものを見てみたいそう
いうものが
ひょっとしてこうDNAに刻みつけられ
てるんじゃないかなと思った出来事でした
でこうやってですねあの10年あまり
いろんな世界各地で
隙を通じて冒険して遊んできたんですけど
もこれがまた仕事としてつながってきます
2009年2010年が僕はですねあの
日本の南極観測隊それの調査のサポートを
する
フィールドアシスタントという仕事で
南極大陸で2ヶ月半
科学者たちが
店頭生活をしながら調査をするそのお
手伝いをするっていう仕事で
南極に行ってきましたで
主な仕事何種類かあるんですけど1つは
隕石探査ですねで
氷の海と言えるような本当に氷河の上を
ずっとスノーモービルでこう1ヶ月近く
探査しましたそうすると
氷の上にこういった隕石が落ちてるんです
ねでそれを収集する仕事をしたんですけど
も実は
我々のこの身の回りにも隕石っていうのは
落ちてます必ず
なんですけどもやっぱり普通の石と混じる
とわからないんですねなので
地球上ではこういった
南極の氷河かサハラ砂漠そういった砂漠で
こういった隕石の収集が行われています
もう一つですね地形の調査に付き合った時
にあの山の山頂が300メートルぐらい
標高差あるんですけどここに行きたいと
いうことで学者の方と山頂に来ましたで
そこに安全に
案内するっていうのも僕の仕事だったん
ですけど
山頂に行くとですねどうでしょうかね
縦にこう岩に線が入っているのわかります
かこれは小学校って言ってその数百万年前
にこの山の上まで
氷の厚さがあって
氷が流れていた後なんですねで僕は素人な
んでこう考えるんですねあ
温暖化したから
雪が減って今日は減ったのかななんです
けどもやっぱり学者の方々が調べると実は
この雪が減った原因は氷河期の時に
南極の
周りの海が凍りついてそこから水分が
南極大陸に補給されなかったのに雪が減っ
たなので
300万円の間をかけてこれだけ雪が減っ
たっていうのを聞いた時に
なんかこう今自分がここに生きのって本当
に奇跡みたいなもんだなっていうふうに
感じてありがたくこう
自然の中で遊ぶということを続けてますで
2013年
再び10年後にまた
グリーンランドに同じ仲間たちと旅をし
ましたやっぱりその10年を経て
我々はやっぱりすごいいい経験を積んで
いるので1年目に行った時よりも3倍
楽しくスキーを滑ることができたんですね
でやっぱりその10年に積み重ねてきた
経験っていうのがすごい生かされてもう一
つちょっと驚いたのは10年前に
クリーンランドに一緒に行ったメンバー7
人のうち僕を含めて3人が南極観測隊で
その安全管理をしているんですねなので
こう世界中でこう遊んできたそういう経験
がこう
社会の役に少し当たっているのかなと思う
とちょっと嬉しい気分でした
でグリーンランドでこうキャンプを貼った
んですけどもこのキャンプ地を選ぶときっ
ていうのはやっぱりこう風に守られる
波に守られるあといい水があるそういう
ような観点でキャンプ地を選ぶんですけど
もそこでこうやじりを見つけるわけですね
でここはやっぱりイヌイットの人たちも
きっとこう安全な場所だっていうことで
ここで生活してたと思うんですねでこれを
見た時にやっぱりこう自分が自然の中で
活動してきて磨いてきたなんかこう根源的
な
センスというか感覚っていうものがその昔
の人とそんなに変わってないんだなリンク
してるんだなっていうのを感じた時にこう
いう
体験っていうのは僕にとってはすごい手動
だからこれは続けていきたいっていうふう
に思いました
で2013年と2003年に滑ったこの
同じ場所なんですけどもやっぱり10年
っていうスパンで見るとまあ雪は減って
いるやっぱり気候変動っていうのはあるの
かなと思うのでやっぱり自分の遊び場を
こう
声長く
保っていくためにはそういったことにも
意識を持たなきゃいけないなと感じてます
でこれ2013年の3月に
北海道で猛吹雪があって8名の方が
亡くなった2日間猛吹雪があったんです
けどもやっぱり自然っていうのは
素晴らしい体験景色とかを与えてくれるん
ですけどもやっぱり時には残酷な一面も
見せますでもやっぱりそれって自然その
ままなんですねでやっぱり人間っていうの
は
自然の中での感覚をやっぱりもう少し持っ
た方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で1つこう僕のおすすめとしてはそういっ
たこう
野生の勘を取り戻すために一番早い道は
山に行って野宿をすることですそうすると
より神様が厳しい中で服の大切さあと
明かりがすごいそれだけ重要だっていう
ことが気づいたりあとは暖かい
燃料が必要だということに気づいたりあと
は例えば風が吹いてカサカサカサカサこう
草が鳴るだけですごいビクッとするような
やっぱりいかにこう自分が今現代のこの
文化に守られてるんだっていうのを気づく
ことができるのでこの野宿っていうのは
すごい僕がおすすめするところです
で本当にあの自然というのは
とても人間にとって必要なことあとはこれ
からの時代あのすごいこう気候変動が起き
てすごい自然がこう猛威を振るような場面
が増えてきますけどもそういった時にこう
人が生き残る何かヒントがきっと隠されて
いると思いますなのでまああの記憶となく
ぜひ遊びというスタンスで
ぜひ自然の中に入る時間を増やして
いただいて
地球に生きるということを皆さんにはもう
少しこう考えていく時間を持って
いただければなと思います
最後にですねあの6年生の時に僕が小学校
の文春に残した文章をお見せしたいと思い
ます
遊ぶ
僕が好きなのは遊ぶことだ
疲れていたって楽しい遊びだったらなんぼ
でもできる大人にも絶対必要なのが遊ぶ
ことだだから
僕は遊びが好きだ
ぜひ
皆さんもこれ遊びって書いてますけども
ぜひお伝えしたいことは自然の中でぜひ
たくさん体を動かして遊んでほしいなと
思います
以上で今日の話を終わりたいと思います
ありがとうございます
[拍手]